yesterday I was super depressed I don't
know why I mean I would he didn't even
want me to have yeah I just yeah I just
kind of draw after the store are you
like I drove around town I was just like
well I would drive by a brick wall to
just read you know before every birthday
before he came home to a Brazilian body
spray yeah the Brazilian body spray his
spirits did you like the smell of it but
I really view like the smell of it but
um every birthday do the day before
you're just kind of what it is is this
and I do I do a couple of things I go on
my Instagram to feel shitty and good
well you this accident because who you
follow right so it's like you know like
today I saw GBO yang at the Emmys loves
you I know I love them too and we were
doing a movie together that let me I
wish dragon is it's great but then uh
so the but I'm just being real I'm not
at 47 puppet doesn't hide I just say
however or whatever I feel okay and then
um but then I'll go to like I'll see
like dad in a dressing room
like at a clothing store take a photo of
a jacket he's wearing and it makes me
happy so you know it's you know yin yang
it's not deep highs and low it's like a
bipolar it's just a fun little ride but
then it's like you know at the end of
the day you know we had a damn near
conniption earlier because you like the
comedy store didn't put up an Instagram
didn't say happy birthday to me out of
yelling what did you say he goes he goes
he goes look at the post before today's
and I looked at it it was a video but I
didn't know I was in the video
but they did say happy birthday so I
yell my yelling for no [ __ ] reason
little well I was going because heat
they put Jimmy Carr a week ago in my
head I'm like I like Jimmy Carr but
she's not he's there twice a year I'm
there every night right so I was
thinking where's mine but then it was up
and then I made look myself look like a
fool but you know what I'm not
embarrassed by stuff like that because
I'm a feeler mm you know and I wear
everything on my sleeve and I make
mistakes and I'm phool the other night
one of those things happen again what
where a white man told me what to do and
I did what he said to do I thought you
said you weren't gonna do I know but I
just I and I was mad for like three
blocks please set it up scenario I was
at the Comedy Store I was driving I'm
sanding sitting there at the stoplight
like on Sunset and Fairfax and I was
like I picked up my phone right cuz Eric
Griffin uh texted me and I get a honk
I'm at a red light and I look over and
this is white guy wearing a like a
baseball some college baseball hat
probably 50 year old white guy white
hair wearing you know he dressed like
Ron Howard he had the baseball cap but
then a nice shirt right so I thought it
was gonna be like I love you on that
before yeah so ruled I smile that let me
go put your phone away no yeah and I go
yes sir and I put it down and he drove
off in the light turn he drove on and I
drove for three blocks yes he's your
master
I know give all right what'd you do
what'd you do Bobby but you did but you
said I know
[Music]